Also haben wir eine sehr interessante Verlosung,
weil wir hier Sujis und jede CD haben, die Emily angefasst hat,
und wir haben T-Shirts
klein ja entweder ich bin die art von rose
auf einem lager oder die toilette ist einfach
t-shirts bei emily position und wieder
okay zenza eher nicht ich bin ich sehe
stärker aus also die frage wie oft
ich das wort sage  flieg in die aufzeichnung und
du bekommst ein autogramm von emily auf
alles ja sicher auf alles in
erzähl uns ein bisschen für veranstaltungsorte leicht berechnet
ja ich bin ein konstanter ausblicke ist in ordnung
okay vielen
dank ja danke fürs mitmachen klick  zoom die erste
online oh danke es war sehr die
erste online show bei der ich war oh du warst bei
okay huh ich war in der show aber ich war
auch in der show okay weiß das es so
schlimm ist wie meine muse nicht okay es ist gutes silber
Kern ist Ihr Englisch, es ist wirklich schlecht.
Sehen Sie Ihr Englisch, Sie Mittwoch, mein
Englisch ist b  und du etwas englisch ist schlecht
okay okay okay was nicht ist
eigentlich sehr gut okay gut
du